I haven't even gone on my mid-life crisis
shopping spree yet what do you get for yours
The Avengers
Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie
this will be my Marvel secret invasion episode one
video there are a whole bunch of Easter eggs and
references so we'll break it all down if you're
brand new to the channel I'm doing videos for all
the episodes just like the other Marvel Disney
plus Series be sure to subscribe to get them we're
also doing a giveaway for Disney plus memberships
all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber and
post your favorite moment from the episode on the
video careful for spoilers if you have not seen
the episode yet because we'll be talking about
everything we'll just start at the beginning and
work our way through shop by shot talking about
Easter eggs and WTF moments starting with the
episode titled Resurrection which is a reference
to Nick Fury basically coming back to earth like
they're resurrecting Nick Fury because he's kind
of been dead to the world so to speak for the last
couple of years since Avengers end game during
the episode several characters references like him
being gone on the saber space station the way that
he explains it he was just broken by what happened
the events of the snap he is a PTSD flashback to
Avengers Infinity war after Thanos snapped The
Infinity Gauntlet so it sounds like he's still
dealing with the trauma of that well but there'll
be a lot more references to this throughout the
series they also reference a saber space station
several times in the episode and it'll be a big
location during the Captain Marvel 2 movie the
Marvels they start with a brand new version of the
Marvel standard intro logo title it's way quicker
than the ones before and I think what they're
doing now is they're going to use this short one
for all the Marvel Disney plus series like this
and they'll say the longer versions of the Marvel
Studios intro logo for the movies only but the
opening scene is of Everett Ross coming back even
though it's not really Everett Ross it's a skrull
pretending to be him you remember he was arrested
by a Val at the end of black panther will Connor
forever and Escape so essentially he's a fugitive
from Justice so the fact that he was working here
as part of this yeah look he was still doing
his regular duties should have been kind of
suspect this is meant to pick up in the year 2025
around the spring and that's about the current
era in Marvel right now like all the movies
that are happening around this period they're
in Moscow and is contacted by an agent Prescod
played by Beric Dondarrion from Game of Thrones
friends how many times have you brought me
back it's the Lord of Light brings you back
closest thing to a flaming sword in the MCU that
we have is Kit Harington's Black Knight with the
Ebony Blade it is funny to see a bunch of Game
of Thrones actors especially Emilia Clarke who's
playing Talos' daughter during the series show
up in the MCU now cannot wait to see if we'll
ever see any crossover between Emilia Clarke's
character and kit Harrington's Black Knight
character don't I remember you from somewhere have
you ever tried to kill me before he's gone full
Charlie Day Theory Meme and learned about this
evil sect of Scrolls Graphics group inside the
good group who's infiltrating different nations
taking over world leaders orchestrating all
these Terror attacks and learns about the dirty
bomb that they plan to set off or the dirty bot
multiple bombs that they plan to set off in Russia
shortly he wants him to contact Nick Fury bring
him down from the saber space station they also
use a lot of these types of scenes in the episode
for exposition like big info dumps they reveal
graphic in the others blame Nick Fury and Captain
Marvel for failing to find them a new world to
live on for the past 30 years that was part of a
promise that they made to them after the events of
the Captain Marvel movie third 30 years ago a lot
of people wondering about this too like they had
30 years to worry about this even though Thanos
the snap The Infinity Gauntlet Avengers Infinity
War Avengers endgame all that stuff even the first
Avengers movie didn't happen until many years
later what else was going on during the 90s that
Nick Fury didn't have time to find them another
plant to live on is a big big universe they also
make several references to Captain Marvel in the
episode too like she bailed on us just like you
bailed on us Nick Fury there'll be many references
to this especially in the Marvels movie they did
this during the Miss Marvel movie too because
part of the joke is that Captain Marvel is
never around but part of the idea here is that
gravic wants to start a war between Russia and
the United States by blaming the attack on Unity
Day from a United States group so part of the idea
is that the skrulls are trying to get the humans
to take care of themselves like mutually assured
destruction making it easier for graphics group
of skrulls the larger group of skrulls to just
kind of move in the ashes and live they don't need
to fight a war if the humans kill themselves then
they bring back the real version of Maria Hill it
is the real one the twist here is that it's not
evil skrulls chasing after it it's actually Talos
and we learned that he himself was a skrull R.I.P
barracked and Darien that's part of the ironic
joke there too like as crazy as he was he was
right about everything when they make the Everett
Ross skrull reveal in the Talos reveal when they
start panning out on the shot you see purple
lighting Illuminating the street that's purple
for the skrulls suits then they transition to the
custom secret Invasion titles which are green for
skrulls even though the green and the big bot
like the nuclear explosion makes it seem very
hulk-like it's meant to represent their dirty bomb
that they're planning on setting off as well as
the idea that they're trying to get the humans
to destroy each other this is their larger ship
that you saw during the Captain Marvel movie
this is more of their true plan all the ships
floating over New York City about to descend
to take over in force kind of like the end of
the comic book secret Invasion storyline this is
Nick Fury this is the evil skrulls in Russia as
part of the big plot in this episode because most
of the series takes place in Russia this is them
impersonating the police just more foreshadowing
for them impersonating people of authority world
leaders this is London representing all the Sonia
fallsworth storyline the skrulls shaking hands
with the human is meant to represent Nick Fury's
alliance with Talos like their relationship coming
together in the good skrulls that are actually
trying to live in harmony with humans this is
meant to represent the skrulls replacing the U.S
president and other world leaders so I do think
early theory is that they will try to replace
Dermot mulrooney's U.S president this is Emilia
Clarke's character she's playing Talos' daughter
named Gaia she was a little girl in the Captain
Marvel movie Gaia also means in some languages
earth like it's meant to represent Earth there's
also a metaphor for a flower like a seed from
skrullos their original Planet adapting to life
on Earth she is also meant to be a metaphor for
that seed that her mother brought and adapted to
life on Earth she's meant to be a culmination of
talos's idea of living with humans in harmony but
the idea is that 30 years go by she grows up
into Emilia Clark here and she's just gotten
more bitter about not having a place to to live
and she falls in with this evil group of skrulls
in gravic this is just the culmination of their
plan taking over the entire world as skrull green
takes over the planet the other major thing that
they revealed about the titles here is that they
were created by AI and it was meant to play into
the whole mystery like the paranoia aspect that
people have in real life about AI taking over the
funny connection to upcoming Marvel series too
like the whole idea of AI running amok is Ultron
basically they're supposed to bring that idea back
during the armor wars series and Val is supposed
to be one of the villains during that and she's
supposed to inadvertently resurrect Ultron which
will then run amok there'll be a lot of other
stuff going on during armor wars like they're
bringing Justin Hammer back but Val and Ultron
will be other villains that will appear during
the series then the real version of Nick Fury
comes back from the saber space station finally on
Talos' call about what happened with Everett Ross
like there's a large secret Invasion plot that you
need to worry about right now notice that he's not
wearing the eye patch he's limping because they
have gravity on the saber space station set to
lower so he's just getting used to the gravity on
Earth when they reveal talos's plant he calls it
a Santa milica like I said that's meant to be a
metaphor for their daughter like there's a real
plant that his wife brought and tried to grow on
Earth successfully but their daughter is meant to
be the real culmination of that whole concept
when he references his wife Soren it takes a
while in the episode they reference it a couple
times but apparently gravic killed her at some
point and that's what helps turn Emilia Clarke's
character against him the last time we saw her
was in the Spider-Man far from home post credit
scene when she was impersonating Maria Hill and
Talos was still impersonating Nick Fury which
he references in the episode like we've been
trying to do the good work here do what you
asked for us filling in for you and that's
basically since the end of Avengers end game like
it was real Nick Fury at Iron Man's funeral then
Talos and his wife started impersonating
him and Maria Hill you gotta tell him
it was fine then touching foreheads together like
that is basically the skrulls' way of hugging
people the promise he refers to is the promise
that Nick Fury and Captain Marvel made to the
skrulls to find them a new home and he explains
that he was exiled from the skrull Council because
of the failure to find a new world graphic has
taken his spot on the council and radicalized most
of the skrulls to his secret Invasion plot which
is why there are so many skrulls that are part of
their group so it's not that all the skrulls are
suddenly evil and trying to take over the planet
some of them are just trying to live their lives
with a show later even the ones that are living
on Graphics compound the other thing here too is
that Talos being pushed out of the skrull council
is meant to be a parallel for Nick Fury like Nick
Fury is on the outs he's kind of been in Exile
this whole time too he doesn't have Shield to fall
back on also too it seems like they kill off Maria
hill during the episode they really want Nick
Fury and Talos to feel like they're doing this by
themselves Maria Hill explains a little bit more
about Graphics true plan to start a war between
Russia and the United States like they want to
sit the bomb off blame the United States group
so that it will lead to a war between Russia and
the United States and it's just a coincidence that
Russia is in the middle of a war in real life like
they wrote these episodes that plotline way before
Russia ever went to war with the Ukraine so it's
just one of those many examples the last couple of
years of real life being Stranger Than Fiction
tying to this idea though we go back to the
White House in the United States and we learned
that Rhodey has become the president's military
advisor since Avengers endgame in the current U.S
president is being played by Dermot mulrooney I
don't know how long he's been in office they talk
about Nick Fury coming back and the president is
worried and Roadies also kind of worried because
it seems like Nick Fury has abandoned the saber
space station and they basically tasked him with
building it which they call the most advanced
space defense platform in the history of humanity
it's meant to be a reference to the sword space
station in the comics which they call the Peak
the whole idea is that Shield is meant to protect
everything internally on planet Earth sword was
meant to protect everything coming from outer
space part of the reason why they can't use the
sword name or the sword space station where they
call it the same labor space station has said
is because they burned the sword organization
during the One Division Series they're calling
the space station something slightly different
fun fact too the sword space station was created
by Joss Whedon in the X-Men Comics which is why
it took them so long to introduce it in the MCU
took a little while to get the rights to those
X-Men comics and those X-Men characters back in
the comics it's run by Abigail brand it's been
featured in a lot of the cartoon series you may
have seen before there's an early Theory right
now that Emilia Clarke's character will become
a bigger character in the MCU going forward and
she'll become Nick Fury's new right-hand person
and run the saber space station and become kind
of like a version of Abigail brand in the MCU
there's already been a lot of fan art of her as
Abigail brand as well and for those of you asking
about what happened with sword after one division
Tyler Hayward is still meant to be in prison so
I think sword the organization still exists but
they're still kind of under lock and key like they
basically fired everybody that works there and for
instance Monica Rambo is working with Nick Fury
up on the saber space station let's say we saw
her in the Marvel's trailer basically doing work
for him so most of the important people at swords
seem like they're working for Nick Fury in outer
space now when they're walking up the White House
steps two they pass by Reagan's painting here like
it's relatively accurate to the real life white
house but part of the joke here is that Reagan
was the US president the sort of the Star Wars
program which is basically what they're talking
about with the saber space station it's like the
ultimate culmination of that in the MCU in real
life George Lucas was a boss for not trying to sue
the US government for stealing his movie name
Nick Fury winds up getting abducted by Olivia
Coleman who's playing Sonja fallsworth who's the
daughter of the original Union Jack they make a
couple references to the comic book origin story
these characters in the Union Jack relationship
with Captain America the original comic book Nick
Fury all the stuff with the Helen Commandos that
took place in the comics and then during the
Captain America first avenger movie in the
MCU she's meant to be kind of like the British
version of Val running MI6 getting into James
Bond territory kind of like the MCU version of M
but you're meant to get a very I'll kind of vibe
from her character like she is Hardcore the Paul
Robeson reference is to a jazz musician in real
life who worked in spycraft during World War II
as well helping the United States government is
also meant to be a reference to Captain America in
the Howling Commandos in World War II the reason
she references him specifically is a notch to Nick
Fury's Origins as a member of the comic book Helen
Commandos during the comics all the characters
are way older they were introduced much earlier
in history so the original Nick Fury was part of
World War II in the Hallen Commandos but in the
MCU they've shifted the timeline forward so this
Nick Fury was born in the 50s but the other idea
is that her father was the original Union Jack
and fought with Captain America in the MCU as part
of the Howling Commandos so they go way back in
the MCU like they talk about working together in
spycraft during the Cold War but then also it's in
reference to them going way back in the comics one
of the other references with the clocks that they
make here like all the clocks everywhere I think
is a metaphor for the Doomsday Clock that the
government keeps like the countdown to destruction
basically like like the countdown to Annihilation
which is kind of where things are headed with this
skrull secret Invasion plot they reveal Nick Fury
has known graphic for a long time and I think part
of the idea like they reveal skrulls live for a
very long time so even if they look younger in
present day like their middle age technically
they're meant to be very very old but part of
the idea is that graphic used to be one of the
good skrulls and then just slowly over time grew
bitter at them not finding a home in eventually
radicalized and now they have the secret Invasion
plot they reference Thanos the events of the
snap would happen to Nick Fury how it changed
them so much like I said he has a PTSD flashback
to getting snapped and part of the idea is they
wanted Nick Fury to seem very different from
pre-ph Thanos Nick Fury like originally the idea
is that Nick Fury was always three steps ahead
of everyone always playing this four-dimensional
chess game he always had a plan he's the person
that brought the Avengers together which they
referenced in the episode in a kind of a funny
way but they wanted him to experience a crisis of
Faith temporarily he will eventually rally he will
help put together the next Avengers team but part
the idea here is that Sonya Fallsworth is meant
to be kind of an antagonist who's friendly to Nick
Fury but he says she has a Scorch Earth policy and
she'll kill any skrull that she comes across they
try to make you feel like Talos is really against
this like he's a pacifist at heart he doesn't want
to harm his own people so they're trying to stop
the secret Invasion plot before Sonia fallsworth
finds an excuse to kill all the skrulls we
meet Emilia Clarke's Gaia character working
with Graphics group at one of their Russian power
plants one of their compounds quote unquote that
they live at that's meant to be the big reveal
here like who her character really is they
technically don't reveal it till later when he
finds her in the alleyway but the whole thing is
that she had disappeared for years we didn't know
what happened to her and this is where she's been
with this group of skrulls that are trying to take
over the planet when she calls it new skrullos
that's meant to be their new capital skrullos is
the name of the original skrull Homeworld they'll
probably talk more about what happened to it
during the series but part of the idea is in
the MCU the skrulls are meant to have lost their
home while it was destroyed during the cree skrull
war so in the original Comics the skrulls were
the villains in the cree were the good characters
they kind of Switched that in the MCU a lot of
what's happening with the cree skrull War and
the backstory what really happened to the skrulls
are meant to play into the Marvel's movie like the
cree are big villains big antagonists during the
Marvel's movie but I think part of the other idea
too is that this other group of skrulls calls the
Earth new skrullos like they'll just replace the
term with new skrullos when she says there's about
500 skrulls living there part of what they want
to show you is that most them don't care about
the secret Invasion most of the skrulls are just
trying to live their lives peacefully then they
start revealing the Warriors the members that are
part of Graphics group she says the longer the
skrulls hold their human form the harder it is
to detect people and I think this is meant to
play into the idea that some of the Avengers
characters like the really big MCU characters
have secretly been skrulls since Avengers end
game maybe even before that and that's why we're
not learning about it until now because they've
held that human form they've been replacing those
Avengers characters for so long one of the early
theories about the series is that Roadie is going
to be one of these skrulls like he'll have been
a skrull since at least of Avengres Endgame and
part of the idea is that they're using his special
access to the US president to eventually replace
the president then they actually show them the
process the skrulls used to replace someone and
how they steal their memories he's kind of got a
teaser for this during the first Captain Marvel
movie with the electrodes in their brain the way
they steal their memories but all these people
they have hooked up are the people that they are
slowly replacing the series in general is supposed
to lay the path for Thunderbolt Ross to become the
US president and I think part of the idea is that
they'll find out what happened in like the end of
comic book secret Invasion Norman Osborne took
credit for getting rid of the skrulls in the
MCU Val and Thunderbolt Ross will take credit for
getting rid of the skrulls in maybe early Theory
they kill off this U.S president Dermot mulrooney
so it creates a need for a new U.S president
and Thunderbolt Ross just rides that wave of
popularity into office I think that he's supposed
to be the US president by the events of Captain
America before but it might happen before that
I don't think it's going to happen during this
series I think we'll just find out something will
happen to the U.S president by the end of this
series and that'll sort of create the vacuum where
Val and Thunderbolt Ross will find opportunity
so they're giving a lot of this Marvel Phase
5 dark rain plot line that Norman Osborne had to
Thunderbolt Ross and Val but that's basically the
way things happen in the comics like it went
from Secret Invasion big crossover Avengers
X-Men Marvel wide title event to dark rain this
series in particular mostly sets up that as an
earth-based plot not so much the Kang Multiverse
War plot which is more of the cosmic stuff heading
into Avengers 5. they'll deal with that during
series like Loki like the other big space based
series but that's part of the victory that she
references when she says Beyond these doors lies
Victory it's the whole idea of them replacing
all these world leaders what are the other new
details that I don't think that they revealed
in the original Captain Marvel movie is that
skrulls have the power to just put their hands
on people and absorb their Memories the bomb that
Nick Fury uses his listening device to find out
about is what they've set off at the the end of
the episode we meet gravic's character played by
Kingsley benedir his daughter talos's daughter is
there the book she's reading is how to understand
the human mind a callback to them just literally
reading the memories of humans Talos reveals
that he's 136 years old like I said by human
standards he's only about 40 so skrulls are meant
to live for hundreds of years Nick Fury also says
that his midlife crisis was forming The Avengers
there'll be a lot more references to the Avengers
in general during the series then we have Maria
Hill versus Talos' daughter and this is just meant
to set up the reveal that she is talos's daughter
like they don't actually reveal it till this
moment when he finds her they explained why she
left why she's so pissed off at him right now but
set the seed for her turning sides with the idea
that graphic secretly killed her mother and she
didn't know until now like Talos is revealing that
to her it was graphic the person you're serving
killed your mother not sure when that happened I'm
assuming sometime just before the series picked up
they also use this Maria Hill versus Emilia Clarke
fight to show you that skrulls are way stronger
naturally than humans Nick Fury references his
time as an agent during the Cold War era based on
his age right now in the MCU he's probably talking
about the 70s and the 80s I think he's supposed to
be in his mid 70s in the MCU right now which is
close to how old Samuel L Jackson is in real life
that was one of the jokes in the Captain Marvel
movie which was said in the 90s with a younger
Nick Fury but if you saw him running he ran like
an old man even though they were de-aging his face
so it was like a really young looking person who
ran like a really old man that's why you don't
see them giving Samuel L Jackson a ton of really
hardcore fight scenes Maria Hill starts arguing
with him about bailing on planet Earth having a
crisis of faith and when she says he owes someone
else the person she's referencing is Nick Fury's
wife who will meet on the series that's right
Nick Fury does have a wife in the MCU you notice
they're also playing a chess match that's a bit of
a reference to the X-Men movies with Professor X
and Magneto playing chess with each other but also
Stan Lee had a cameo scene at the end of the first
Avengers movie playing yes in Central Park Talos'
daughter coming back to visit him then is meant to
show you how she started to switch sides like has
it fully happened yet but she's already started
to switch back to help them then the Russian Unity
Day celebration Nick Fury starts being distracted
by graphic he starts to switch between all the
different people that Nick Fury saw the day before
as a way to show Nick Fury we are everywhere
you won't know that it's us until it's too late
graphic impersonates Nick Fury then shooting Maria
Hill in the end the episode with her Bleeding Out
basically they make it seem like she is dead the
way that Nick Fury reacts and takes off she was
only listed in the credits as a special guest star
like Martin Freeman who they killed off during
the episode even though he was a secret skrull so
they really want you to think that she's dead like
Perma dead but I think there's a chance that she
survives and comes back at the end of the series
but like I said I think the idea is that Maria
Hill has been Nick Fury's right-hand person this
whole time in the MCU and now they want to sort
of clear the path and make that Emilia Clark's
character so it is possible that she is dead
let me know in the comments do you think that
Marie Hill is Perma dead or if you think it'll
be a big fake out and Marvel will bring her back
at the end of the series she is also one of the
big Agents of Shield references because she was
such a big character during that series there's
a lot of theories that we'll also see some Agents
of Shield characters from the TV show show up in
the MCU through secret Invasion possibly future
series as well too but like I said I think long
term they want Emilia Clarke's character sort
of becoming the Abigail brand of the MCU or at
least using that name as an alias and running
the sword or the saber space station for Nick
Fury it's one of those Kit Harington things like
they introduced them in a relatively minor seeming
role but they have potential to become much
much bigger characters like kit harington's
Black Knight still waiting for them to do more
with the Black Knight character big reminder
there are six episodes total if you spotted any
other Easter eggs or references in this episode
that I didn't mention in the video just write
them below in the comments my episode 2 trailer
video will post on Thursday in my full episode
2 video will post next week after they release
it Marvel also just announced that they basically
cancel their Comic-Con plans no big Marvel panel
or anything like that so I might do a video about
that just explaining what's going on but there's a
bunch of other stuff that's happening this week
and coming up so make sure to enable alerts for
my channel so you don't miss any of that stuff
everyone click here for my episode 2 trailer
video I'll update the link as soon as I post that
and click here for all my other secret Invasion
videos thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!